freunde herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge ein tag persönlicher koch
ich den ihr heute beim halt es ist
endlich soweit so viele instagram
nachrichten kommentare ein veganer wgs
sechs jahren gegangen
das ist natürlich eine freude für mich
diese challenge anzunehmen also nicht
wirklich eine chance gehabt geil rezepte
ausgesucht wir starten mit einem tofu
scramble mit cherry tomaten und frischem
brot war das habe ich übrigens in den
einen den sechs jahre nicht einmal gsl
wirklichkeit ist einmalig habe
recherchiert und toskana ist ja so dass
veganer rührei habe ich zumindest
gehaltvoll beliebte auch leer aber wer
weiß vielleicht ist es natürlich einst
du eigentlich wie deine erinnerungen
dafür hätte ich hasste wirklich früher
habe ich auch schon seit dem zeitpunkt
die einmal wieder gegessen
ich bin richtig gespannt ob das
irgendwie diese geschmacklos wieder alle
richtigen weg waren sehr gut und ist le
clos du plötzlich ganz gespannt
zurückholen das ist viel spannender
verlief lakers
also ich glaube schon feststellen ist
durch eine sehr frische küche dies auch
gut ausgestattet ich habe also auf jeden
fall etwas mit dem ich arbeiten kann ich
zeig euch das mal was wir alles brauchen
also wieso salz pfeffer
dann habe ich hier treffen zusammen 450
gramm welche gehe davon aus dass nicht
auch ordentlich hunger hat teil tomaten
hefe flocken brot kurkuma und ich habe
hier eine scramble tofu würzmischung ich
bin normalerweise kein gigantischer fan
von würzmischungen weil ich meine das
ist ja auch einen teilaspekt des kochens
dass man halt selbst wird nach geschmack
und sonstwie aber ich war auf der suche
nach karl marx als das ist schon
schwefel salz aus indien und das durch
diesen schwefelanteil seinen
eigengeschmack da drin ist einfach nur
kurkuma für die farbe also im prinzip
ist das gar nichts besonderes wenn
nichts gefunden hat ich selbst gemacht
aber wir kriegen hoffentlich dadurch so
die konsistenz von einem geilen rührigen
das ganze ein bisschen cremiger zu
machen habe ich hier noch so joghurt
geholt ich geben weil hier die fahne
hinein
wir wollen uns aber auch nicht zu heiss
er soll nicht so viel bekommt und wir
raten den ein wenig an wie jetzt machen
wir den puck ganz groß klein weil er
wird noch weiter auseinander fallen in
der zubereitung wir wollen wirklich am
ende noch so chance haben von unserem
damit hier so einem klassischen rhein
nahe kommt so hier gebe ich ein bisschen
wasser rein und da wollen wir dann
unsere mischung an
jetzt kommt dieser schwefelgeruch kraft
auch wenn das mit wasser benetzt attack
series komplett nach dem kopf vor nikci
ab wir das schild ist es nicht okay das
ist heftig mexiko heftig das ist der
klassische klassische um die ohren dass
die kaufkraft fortführen und veganer wie
kann ich wieder einmal über den papa bis
auf und sei wesentlich auf unser
liebstes ersatz machen ausprobiert weil
ich wohl ja schon nicht so sehr der
fleisch- fisch- must have to ja ich mir
dass alles so egal was da drin ist
fertig ist doch so leicht gibt hat das
dort zusätzlich weil es mir einfach egal
beachten der ganzen kirche nicht sein
also die schwerterin natürlich dieses
karl marx fest
ich wünsche ihr könnt ihr das riechen
leute das riecht so intensiv dass mir
fast denken würde das ist schon fast
schlecht wäre so intensiv ist aber es
kann ja gar nicht schlecht weil es keine
ist und unser so jung und macht das
ganze noch training also und gerade
kriegen auf jeden fall eine schöne
konstanz 100 200 gramm drauf und ich
will das mit einem runter jetzt 180 grad
so unser vegane früher lassen wir hier
oben so ein bisschen vor sich hin
köchelt durch genau die konsistenz hat
wir wollen also ein bisschen
feuchtigkeit muss noch raus dabei hilft
uns auch bedingt geschmack noch ein
bisschen hefe flocken es war gebe ich
davon so drei gehäufte esslöffel darüber
findet das ganze die finanzen noch mehr
schmeckt und jetzt halten wir das ganze
so weil wir wollen hält die großen
blöcke sage ich mal intakt gehalten aber
ansonsten kann ich da drin
rom gerne ein bisschen flocken bilden
das ist eine klassische konsistenz
bekommt er schon wieder mit elektrischem
ewigkeit
es kann auf jeden fall das war mein gott
legt eine mühle ist mir ins auge fallen
scheiße ich habe mir einfach nur so
gedrückt und das ist was du raus
geflogen dann wenn ich das ins finstere
sachen alle die jetzt vielleicht wird
vielleicht aber das klingt irgendwie
keine ahnung fünf bisher ist es besser
einfach einfach so viele leben ich finde
es auch sehr schwierig aber es ist schon
in so einem battle weil für mich ist so
das ultimative chef gefühlt also koch
gefühl mit so einer minute
ok als drittes ist natürlich auch das
was frisch tepper mal ja sie es jetzt
mit schön dicke scheiben brot prof unser
brot wissen wir ein bisschen blieben die
beiden seiten natürlich lässt sich das
einmal schöne an und wir gehen zum
anderen auf den boxer tomaten
geschnitten und wir sehen uns wenn das
ganze fertig ist
[Musik]
kraft nach höherem
jetzt bin ich gespannt also du hast du
schon so ein bisschen warten ich habe
schon probiert fabian kontaktieren wird
also ich weiß schon wie es schmeckt naja
das läuft bei mir immer so nimmt jetzt
mal einige weil wir wollen ich gar nicht
groß stören beim essen sehen wir dann
auch wertes zu bewerfen ok ok wilmsberg
wir haben da ein bisschen geschnackt
über pc erkennt wir haben es irgendwann
was sagst du nicht herzlich schmeckt
sehr sehr geil
der geist also ich habe auch schon
gesagt dass ich finde es hat nicht mehr
sondern ein tofu eigenen speicher markt
verbuchte sehr gerne es gibt viele leute
das irgendwie abschreckt ja es hat
wirklich so eine konsistenz gehabt wie
rührei und man hat im kopf gar nicht
dass es prof der krimi und bleibt euch
mit dem brot quatchi das war richtig
lecker wolken 1 bis 10 vor allen dingen
auch mit den tomaten dazu ich mache das
sehr gerne und man fühlt sich richtig
energies finden sie garantiert sind es
in berlin fürchtet er einfach ein
richtiges protein 18 war okay das
gedacht ist ein starker staat und teils
auch super lecker und es ist für mich
auch wirklich wenn ich mich ein bisschen
früher dem werden beides gleich ein
mittagessen wird freundlich habe den
armen liegt relativ lange warten lassen
es tut mir sehr leid denn ist gerade
noch mal siehst
ich habe mit sebastian gemeinsam laden
auch glaser bleibt ohne interessantes
video auf jeden fall muss hier gas geben
ich habe hier so ein baguette geholt da
schneiden wir uns zwei schöne stücke
raus jemand das ganze so wie melanie
sandwiches das heißt dass quasi ein
komplett in der mitte ist ein zitiert
ist mit dass wir dafür maschine nehmen
hier ist unsere maschine dann schneiden
wir auch vorne und hinten schon acht in
relativ großzügig abschneiden
hier sieht man es ganz gut dass ich
schon mal schön geworden so sollte das
ganze aussehen die decke ist gut von mir
schon aufgefallen ich muss jetzt gleich
nichts gesamtes öl klar und ich habe
nämlich vergessen noch mal wenig zu
kaufen
schnell ist doch ganz grob die schale an
der seite damit gleich über als unser
paniermehl aufgreift und wir setzen das
von beiden seiten so haben wir das ganze
jetzt werden den weiteren zubereitung
stehen außerdem benötigen wir zwei
mittelgroße tomaten die ich ganz leisten
deren tomaten mit salz und pfeffer sind
der ultimative geschmacks booster uns
wird jeder art schön töten scheiben aus
dem tomaten schneiden dass dir das noch
schön salzen können jetzt gleich der
wahre vorteil man kann beides
gleichzeitig machen
wir wären gleich auf dem sandwich
außerdem diese veganem einem lesen
nutzen ich sage euch leute
das ist krass aber wir sind ja auch der
sich schon seit ich glaube ich kann
eigentlich sogar schon anfangen und hier
hinten diesen topf 4 aufsätzen zum
frittieren der top hier wird richtig
heiß und ich gebe einfach die gesamte
flasche hinein das pferd jetzt hier
quasi so ein bisschen ab und das machen
wir uns zunutze und trocknen quasi die
feuchtigkeit wie das salz entzogen
achten mal schön trocken sein abtrocknen
ihr seht schon die verliererstraße
penker brems doppelseitiges nehmen in
der mitte während normalerweise eier
wir machen das ganze mit 130 liter
kaltem wasser 40 grad weit 47 g
speisestärke und unser wasser ihr seht
hier das ist ganz flüssig damit können
wir schon paniert packen uns einen
oberen dann benutzen wir sie mit dem
feinen mail
das sieht das ganze ausgeht ist jetzt
meine nachbarn manchmal nämlich diesmal
hinbekommen so einmal komplett den
netzteilen und ging es zum schluss auf
die pankower programms und und über
bekommen auch noch mal ordentlich welche
und wird jede stelle muss bedeckt sein
und dann sieht das ganze so aus bottrop
in unsere koteletts frei und so warten
wir jetzt von beiden seiten golden brand
konserviert habe ich schon zurecht
geschnitten schabacker wäre auch super
ab und an hört mal übels christi dann
jetzt während sie noch schön warm sind
gehen wir schon den käse obendrauf oder
käse ist schön angespielt
das hier ist noch mal leicht angetastet
eine post habe ich das ganze damit die
mario nicht das brot ausreichend davon
nehmen wir jetzt auf jeden fall
reichlich weil es ist nicht ganz gesund
aber er sollte auf die unterseite ist
die huber group oder noch ein bisschen
öl darüber natürlich salz und pfeffer
dann platzieren wir unsere kotelett jede
menge von unseren tomaten auf die
oberseite
ich mache das ganze unglaublich sagt ich
[Musik]
hier sitzen wir also hier drüben ist
übrigens parallel der stream an und für
uns ist ja nur einmal reinbeißen und
dann erst sehen wir uns wieder ein 6 1
das gibt sehr gut aus das könnt ihr euch
liebe sandwiches ausprobieren wieder
freude haben aufgegessen und ich bin
ganz hart wie man sich daran gefallen
wir schauen dass du sagst
also ich finde mich hat das als erstes
hat es mich so ein bisschen anders also
ein fisch ist fisch sandwich also eine
fiche palette an der sache dran war
natürlich vom geschmack dann ein
bisschen kräftiger und ein bisschen
fleischersatz mäßig das hat man schon
gesteckt die mayo richtig geil ist
grünkohl rucola oder effekt mit drin
weil sagen programm habe ich am ende
nicht ob ihr das gesehen haben
es hat perfekt gesättigt nach diesem
frühstück die proteinreiche frühstück
jetzt noch mal sowas zum snack zu haben
der richtigkeit sättigendes hammergeil
und auch wieder dieses gute sättigen
also nicht dass ungesunde jetzt nicht
dieses liste ist im bauch sondern ist
schon geil gewesen das halbe glas mario
versteckt dass das ich also ich habe
nichts fertiges gekauft sondern ich habe
eine aubergine gekommen 3 mm dick
geschnitten habe die familie zitiert das
war das was ich habe es gerade in der
küche gemacht weil ich habe das so aus
gehört der maschine ist so jung
das ist geht das war mir jetzt kann ich
mich hat hat im kopf wie das das ist
schon ein ersatz stück ist was du einen
aus der packung in die pfanne genommen
hast oder so wenig ist bekommt erzählt
mir was ist das ganze für eine note für
dich also hat sehr gut geschmeckt würde
ich wieder essen das war eine richtig
geile mischung es hat sehr gut
miteinander geschmeckt auch balsamico
kamen sie
rhein ist für mich eine sieben von zehn
sie lernen heißt das ist gut wir haben
potenzial für das abendessen das risotto
dass wir gleich machen werden und ich
aus wie super lecker wir sehen uns
freude wir kommen zum großen finale des
heutigen tages es gibt ein spargel
risotto glaubensfrage 3d käse thymian
rosmarin rucola gemüsebrühe schalotten
dann habe ich so eine vegane butter
risotto weiß knoblauch und cherry
tomaten also ich mag mein erstes mal
unsere cherrytomaten hier nochmal den
recht ich bin übrig hatten die waschen
wir gleich und dann halbieren wir sie
sondern gebe einfach mein ein
schüsselchen ich habe mir jetzt also
drei ästchen rosmarin rosmarin und
thymian und jetzt zusätzlich das ganze
ein bisschen wenn alles geschafft ist
hacken ist klein dann stand es noch 2
knoblauchzehen und die schneiden wir
relativ feiern wir sind unsere kräuter
hier die zwei knoblauchzehen und hier
die tomaten und wir packen jetzt alles
zusammen daran eben jetzt einen guten
schluck olivenöl 1 2 teelöffel zucker
trick von kevin also kevin romys das
hilft dem ganzen zu karamellisieren
und so eine schöne süße auszubilden es
wird unter anderem später unserer top
hängt aber es wird nicht das einzige
sein denn wir haben den spargel auch im
ofen grüner spargel leute ihr wisst dass
man muss sie nicht schälen und wir
schneiden großzügig und ein bisschen was
ab jetzt werden wir unseren gesamten
spargel ebenfalls ein ölen schon jede
menge muss man es ruhig sagen mach das
jetzt einfach hier drauf wie rhön auch
den spargel komplett ein
wir werden auf dem spargel eine kleine
prise zucker geben weil ich glaube was
bringt alles dann am ende zusammen also
der soll ja auf jeden fall jetzt gut
besetzt sein gebe ich schon um darüber
dass auch das öl hiervon noch ein
bisschen ein dürfen kann
das heißt wir das ganze auch schon mal
können wir es auch schon in den ofen
geben dass man nicht sexy aussieht leute
und wir lassen alles durchgang
während winden recht vorbereiten
verloren jetzt schaffen und diese
platten länglichen und nehmen wir mal so
drei stück die halbieren wir zunächst
und wir dürfen das ganze super für uns
auch schon top schnappen und den auf den
ganzen tag gehen wir jetzt direkt
ordentlich olivenöl hinein
ich habe jetzt die charlotte topf
gegeben und ich schwitze sie ein wenig
an wenn die schalotten angeschwitzt sind
geben wir darauf 300 gramm risotto reis
rainer gramm bei witzen tritt essen
werden wenn alles hier so schön an
geschnitzt ist dann machen wir mit dem
guten schluss reichwein ab und den
lassen jetzt komplett verkaufen
die flüssigkeit vom bein des
größtenteils verkauft und jetzt geben
wir darauf 600 milliliter brühe mit der
brühe lassen wir das ganze jetzt ein
kochen bis die gewünschte konsistenz
erreicht hat und den backofen sieht auch
traumhaft aus spaß sie zu tausenden sind
so wurde ich jetzt schon mehr auch das
alles schon schön eingekocht ich habe
jetzt hier 80 gramm butter bzw die garde
butter die gebe ich auch noch dazu und
die schmilzt jetzt ein und die ruhig ein
die textur ist direkt schon sehr sehr
schön wir geben dazu jetzt aber diese
handvoll von unsere begannen reihe käse
und hören einfach auch noch mitunter
halbfinal aus dem ofen raus sortiert und
jetzt schneide ich so maximal bei drei
zentimeter lange stücke all das gebe ich
jetzt zum risotto dazu und das hier
vorne
die spitzen beweisen wir zum garnieren
[Musik]
geil
das große finale wir haben nachts kommt
der chor zweifacher nach riad und essen
ist eine gute menschen das ist eine
ziemlich mann liegt das große finale
lasst uns pro tier mal haben also das
sieht optisch schon mal ein krasses von
dem was heute gemacht hast willst du
bewertung
ich bin glücklich ja ja weil das das
leckerste war wirklich in letzter zeit
gegessen habe fenster und dieser reißt
so primitive grünspan hat letztens sogar
noch nicht raus gehauen
ja aber letztens sogar noch natürlich
also vielleicht hast du das irgendwie
gespürt aber grüner spargel aber das was
alles getoppt haben ständig leiden
cherrytomaten zellen und ich weiß nicht
wieso ich hab noch niemals eine schelte
mundart und es war so eine
geschmacksexplosion da war einfach alles
geil alles system essen gebe ich mit
zehn von solar oder zehn von zehn glatt
würde ich wieder ist gewiss aber jemand
der das nicht leichtfertig sachen wo ich
sage einfach das ist perfekt und das war
eine perfekte mahlzeit hey leute was für
ein finale für diesen wunderbaren tag es
war sehr interessant hat echt spaß
gemacht auch einfach mal komplett legal
zukommt superlecker von wir sehen im
nächsten video macht's gut besser in
georgia